my name is mocked or in and I'm the
program
director of the Yale Himalaya initiative
and before I introduce our two speakers
and this keynote panel allow me to say a
few words about the initiative in 2011
faculty students and professionals
across Yale University whose work
focuses on the Himalayan areas of Bhutan
china india and nepal and pakistan and
all of the Tibetan and cultural areas
that traverse those states came together
to form the Yale Himalayan initiative
engaging with the Himalaya as a trans
regional space transnational space in
fact for research and practice we aim in
time to create the first comprehensive
interdisciplinary University led
initiative in North America explores the
region as an interconnected whole but at
once recognizes the ecological political
cultural diversity focusing broadly on
the themes of environment of livelihoods
culture we're exploring themes that
transcend dysentery and political
boundaries with research projects are
active on forest use environmental
linguistic diversity migration cultural
transformation and religious life these
projects involve ongoing collaborations
with academics with practitioners and
communities in the Himalayan region
itself as of March this year
participating departments of Yale
include anthropology geology and
geophysics history history of art
religious studies in the college of arts
and sciences and then the professional
schools of Forestry and environmental
studies law medicine public health the
Macmillan center of international
relations in which you find yourself the
global health leadership initiative of
the Jackson Institute the Council on
East Asian Studies and the South Asian
Studies Council as well as many of
Yale's museums and galleries the
initiative has seen considerable growth
since its inception in 2011 and for
specific achievements and activities
include and I'll just touch on them now
first of all a monthly seminar series of
free public lectures and film screenings
that brings many world leaders and
Himalayan studies and scholarship to
Yale many from the region itself we've
hosted lectures on conservation on
environment development cultural
linguistic topics invariably to for how
or very well attended evening's and all
sectors of Yale and also New Haven have
come sometimes these results in your
research projects new collaborations new
grant proposals between Yale faculty and
regional partners second we've developed
a series of interdisciplinary course
offerings here at Yale with high
enrollments in languages cultures
religions and the environment of the
Himalayan region in response to growing
student interest a course from Himalayan
films is offered this summer and in the
summer session of 2014 we hope to have a
regional program in Nepal and Bhutan
Yale has also supported instruction in a
number of less commonly taught languages
spoken in the Himalayan region including
Nepali Tibetan and actually now zanka
through this directed language
independent language study that the
center of language study here manages it
ensures that students have accessed the
necessary linguistic skills they need to
work in the region through a melon
funded grant Columbia Cornell and Yale
are now collaborating to offer several
languages not otherwise taught on our
campus via video conferencing and this
plans to include Tibetan from Columbia
this year third Yale faculty and
students have been in participating in a
round of consultation workshops in the
region in dehradun in 2001 2011 sorry
Kathmandu last year and we're planning
for temple this summer in participation
with colleagues two of whom are here
from the University of Virginia emerging
themes from these workshops in the
region include the need for better
collaboration knowledge sharing and
broad regional thinking finally a
cluster of other activities include a
series of short video interviews with
leading scholars on the region produced
by the initiative and they've just been
released on yells youtube channel today
and also on iTunes University it's a
possible starting point which we've
discussed already in the discussions at
the conference this morning for a free
online some kind of course shared course
initiative and we're very excited by
that as of this month the journal
Himalaya the leading journal of the
Association upon landing lane studies is
co-located at Yale
dartmouth jointly edited by myself
auntie Anna Craig the small exhibit that
many of you saw in the memorabilia room
is another coming together of yells
collections showcasing what we have and
of course this conference I should add
that Yale also has offered to host the
third Himalayan studies conference for
the association of Nepal and Himalayan
studies next year March 14 to 16 with a
focus on communities so please save the
date and be in touch with me if you'd
like to propose panels or sessions that
you'd like to organize so let me turn
now to our speakers the Gorkha King
prickly now and Shah who is not one of
our speakers famously referred to his
fledgling kingdom as a yam between two
boulders this evening I feel a bit like
that yam as I introduced these two great
scholars Charles ramble is an
anthropologist and intimate ologist
since 2009 he's been professor and
director at the aquatic diesel titude in
Paris prior to that he was university
lecturer in Oxford Charles is president
of the international association for
Tibetan studies and has published a
number of seminal books that relate to
his main research interests pilgrimage
burn religion himalayan civil religion
and social history Jim Scott is the
sterling professor of political science
professor of anthropology and also
co-director of the agrarian Studies
program here at Yale and he's a farmer
Jim is intellectually voracious in his
interests covering political economy
comparative agrarians societies theories
of hegemony and resistance peasant
politics revolution and even anarchism
many of his super billion title books
will be known to you all and for that I
will not repeat them but he's introduced
ideas and ways of thinking that have
been formative across the social
sciences allow me to end on a personal
note I've known Charles and Jim Farber
20 years in related of quite distinct
ways I met Charles in Nepal in 1992 and
then read his work later at
cambridge i read jim's work at cambridge
that I met him in New Haven I would
never have imagined that one day I would
have the honor of introducing them to
you today and at this conference would
be the venue for that conversation
Charles welcome to Yale before is yours
I'd like to begin by saying what a great
honor it is for me to be here and I
would like to thank Sarah and Andy for
inviting me to give this keynote
presentation I would also like to say
what an honor it is for me to share the
concealer podium it's actually a pit
with with James Scott who whom I've had
the pleasure of meeting for the first
time today now before I came here Sarah
sent me a completely terrifying set of
instructions about what I should talk
about and essentially the idea was that
I should address the four themes that
came up in the the main part of the the
seminar today that is to say
disciplinary histories geographies
identities everyday religion and the
environment that I should relate this to
the entire corpus of Jane Scott's work
and that somewhere along the way I
should tell the rest of the world why
they should be interested in the
Himalaya and now what mod didn't say is
that my new designation is not as an
anthropologist it is as philologist
philologists don't do the big picture we
do lots of little pictures and that's
more or less what I'm going to try to do
today the other thing that Sarah did
point out is if that lot were not bad
enough is that I should try to adopt an
informal approach a conversational style
so I haven't actually written something
out that I can read so I've I suppose
I've just could try and avoid the
portent a style of the classical keynote
speech and try and be a little chatty
about
what I'm going to say in the next
however many minutes mark allows me in
the background are a number of works
that I'm not going to be citing all the
way through so I will try to relate what
I say to the many of the themes that
have bought certain of the themes that
have brought up in James God's work in
addition to his works I'm thinking
primarily of the art of not being
governed and domination and the arts of
resistance those will be the two that
will be most present i think in what I
say today in addition to that there a
couple of works i should cite because
they're especially relevant to lowest
Sarah also told me to explain whether
the Himalaya was part of Zambia or not
but maybe I'll pass on that one so
another couple of works that are very
relevant one precisely by Sarah called
other centres of Himalayas in Zambia
very fine article published a few years
ago hitherto unpublished volume edited
by David goellner with a fine
introduction by the man himself and then
very significantly several articles
particularly one by Jeffrey Samuel who
as early as around 1993 proposed that
Tibet could be placed in Zambia even
before the names Omiya had been coined
so we need to be aware of that
particular heritage so what as a
philologist can I bring to this mistrust
I think this is eugene veena there the
editor of Mallory's morte d'Arthur who
can be regarded by some as the founder
of textual criticism don't believe
anything you read the first topic I
should address is disciplinary history
then and I'm not going to do go through
the whole thing we had a couple of very
fine presentations of the
history of himalayan anthropology today
mainly by kathy so what i will do is to
be a little bit mistrustful about
certain presentations of the history of
the discipline disciplinary history is
as subjective as any history in the case
of history writ large a marxist will see
history in terms of class struggle
dialectical materialism whereas another
type of historian might consider that
the evocation of these particular
opposition's is completely exaggerated
so the example i would like to give of
conflicting histories or parallel
histories shall we say before i finally
come around to my point which is to talk
about the representation of himalayan
studies is history of mountaineering
mountaineering is actually a subject
that's been rather neglected in the last
couple of days considering that for the
Western world the only reason the
Himalayas were ever interesting is
because you would climb them because
they were there and mountaineering is
actually a terribly important thing when
it comes to national identity and
national pride and unser fourth and we
Westerners haven't got the monopoly on
that attitude the European tradition
concerning the history of mountaineering
would probably go back to pet rocks
famous ascent of mount move on to on the
April the 26th 1336 this is officially
the first time somebody pointlessly
climbed a mountain which is what
mountaineering is all about then the
lineage would probably continue at least
in the British tradition via the famous
ascent of the matterhorn by Edward
whimper and Lord Francis Douglas in 1865
specifically on July the 14th which must
have really upset the French and then
eventually by a circuitous route down to
scent of everest by Tenzing and Hillary
in 1953 Chinese mountaineering is she
would look different officially were
actually Chinese mountaineering began
with Russian cooperation in the 1950s
during the friendship period and the aim
was to make an ascent of mount everest
in 1959 by the way I owe all this to a
work I've recently been reading by maria
luisa nadari of cambridge university
chinese mountaineering began with
Russian cooperation in the 1950s the
plan was to climb Everest as a joint
expedition in 1959 certain things
happened in Lhasa in that year the
expedition was abandoned and eventually
the Chinese climbed it without Russian
assistance the following year recent
histories of Chinese mountaineering
actually trace a different trajectory so
it all begins somewhere about the 3rd
century BC with certain poets who are
given to climbing hills and then other
poets in following centuries who are
also given to hill walking and then as
you might imagine the lineage passes
through the Long March which involved
walking up a lot of mountains and
finally culminating in the successful
ascent of Everest in 1960 there is a
Tibetan tradition as well that has not
been completely subsumed by the PRC
version the source of this really is a
humble who was the VT veton who was on
the famous 1960 expedition interviewed
recently he refused to talk about the
official version of mountaineering in
tibet and he prefers to talk about
sacred landscape he likes to talk about
the fact that the first human being to
ascend to the top of Everest was Padma
Sam bhava and points out also that Kyle
ash was topped by Milarepa so we have
three quite different histories here the
goals of these climbs are different as
well for the 1960 chinese everest
expedition it wasn't just the peak of
ever
that was the goal but it was the
achievement of reaching the summit via
the north face which i quote foreigners
claimed was an impossible feat okay so
forget about the peak anybody could do
that doing it via the north face was the
real challenge and the Chinese succeeded
for the Tibetans paradoxically in a
certain sense it seems to be not to get
to the top of the mountain but to leave
the top of the mountain unscathed as in
the ascent of nanchang bangla so a minor
peak was climbed out of reverence to the
sacred mountain and also we should
remember that gamba was instrumental in
making sure that Kyle ash was out of
bounds for summiteers for European
Continentals for certain of them in any
case the aim is to climb all 14 8,000
meter peaks for the British there are no
14 8,000 meter Peaks there is only one
mountain of 29,000 feet and we got it
so we should be aware that there are
alternative histories and if somebody
proposes one the history of
mountaineering or a discipline we should
immediately look around to see if there
are others we should mistrust what we've
been told one thing I would like to
point out is one thing I would like to
bring up is a presentation we might want
to distrust is a representation that's
cited in Sarah's very fine article she
is not the provenance of it but she does
cite it and it refers to Himalayan
studies as follows that there is i quote
a curious division of labor between West
and anthropologists and Nepali
historians the former the Western
anthropologists tend to focus on village
studies to the detriment of awareness of
the presence of the state whereas the
latter further Nepali historians embed
their work much more squarely in a state
perspective now do we trust this
representation of Himalayan studies to
begin with Western here equates with
English language and it quite ignores
the fact that the French anthropological
tradition in the Himalayas is much more
squarely centered in a historical state
perspective but also why compare Western
anthropologists in the party historians
why compare apples and oranges there are
after all Western historians and Nepali
anthropologists and we should remember
that Western historians there is by the
way a very fine article short article by
John Walton a fine overview of
historical writing on their power in in
recent years and there seems to be a
rather equitable balance between Nepali
and Western historians and Western
historians are just as much state
oriented as their Nepali counterparts
Nepali anthropologists likewise are
probably even less cognizant of the
presence of the state than the
demonized western counterparts we should
remember after all that it was at the
hands of just a cite one example the
Nepali scholars that the contentious
matter of the geroons engagement with
the state was removed from the english
translation of pinheads book this
morning Jeffrey Samuel gave that
marvelous example of two cities sharing
the same set of coordinates but somehow
being in different spaces I think that's
a lovely image and as he said and I
agree with him there a more convincing
division if we're looking for conflicts
in the field is between Buddhist studies
and fieldwork based on apology and this
is exemplified by the spat between
Snelgrove and furihime on Dorf sometime
in the 1960s or 70s in which fura the
snellgrove reviewing furihime adores
Sherpas gave him a mauling for not
taking into account the emek in Tibetan
Buddhist tradition um and I think worth
pointing out that this idea of
colocation having two spaces in one
place is something that's completely
consonant with the kind of situation we
find in the Himalaya at lease at me and
the communities that I have worked with
mark mentioned work on pilgrimage and
sacred space and this is a classic of
course a single Mountain can be two
completely different things on the one
hand it can be a EULA that is to say the
abode of some autochthonous divinity who
receives blood sacrifices and at the
same time seen from a different
perspective this is the abode of some
high tantric divinity in whose honor the
mountainous circumambulated
so two different things happening at
exactly the same point in example by
another example i can think of his as a
particular in a particular community in
southern muslim where i did a certain
amount of fieldwork there was at the top
of the hill that can representing a
local territorial divinity now most of
the time this can was a pile of rocks
and herders and firewood collectors
would simply walk past it as if it were
just a feature of the landscape however
when the head men of the village had to
go and worship the divinity there they
had to approach it in a completely
different way they had to take a
different trail that the old trail the
long trail the difficult trail and in
doing so even though they arrived at the
same set of coordinates they actually
arrived at a different place and then
they were in the presence of the God not
just in the presence of a pile of rocks
and actually at them since we're on the
subject and probably have enough time
I'm an anecdote when we moved to France
about 19 years ago I used to take my
daughter to school and we always walked
along the same trail and one day I
brought her home by a different route I
think it must have been about five years
no she must have been a bit older about
eight years old at the time and so we
came home by a different route arrived
back at the house she had her tea in
silence and then in the end of her tea
she said we came back by a different
route didn't we I said yes I said so
that means this is not my house and you
are not my parents
so if Western scholars have been
negligent of the work of Nepali
historians then the opposite is the case
where Tibetan where Tibet is concerned I
should say that you know I'm I can only
touch on certain corners of this
enormous brief that sarah has given me
and when I when I'm talking about the
Himalayas for the most part I'm going to
be talking about the central him earlier
that is saying the power with a certain
amount about Tibet that'll be in the
second half but with reference to parts
of the eastern Himalaya now this leaves
out an awful lot of him earlier but
can't do everything in the case of
history writing about Tibet scholars
have been particularly dependent on
indigenous Tibetan scholars and this is
substantially determined the kind of
history that's being written it is the
history of prominent people of kings of
sectarian conflict of war of monasteries
and so forth there is no social history
of Tibet social history being as the
founder of the sub discipline GM
Trevelyan said history with the politics
left out or more charitably as Mary
fulbrook booted history with the people
put back in the reason for this as
Curtis said this morning is primary that
there are no sources the kinds of
sources that social historians use are
not there in the case of Tibet most of
them were destroyed during the Cultural
Revolution and what survived is sitting
in the bowels of the Potala Palace about
two million documents in sacks which
nobody has looked at yet in the
Himalayas the story is a different one
such sources are much more available to
particular places come to mind well a
certain amount of work is being done in
ladakh by scholars like dita shoe for
example I'll have occasion to mention
him
again presently places like sikkim and
Muslim Muslim being a district of Nepal
one of the 75 districts of Nepal which
used to be an autonomous Kingdom the
kind of material that these archives
constitute is extremely varied some of
the documentation is official so even if
you go to a village and you find a
document it may well be some missive
from the state informing people about
the kinds of taxes they have to pay
whereas others other categories of these
documents are hidden transcripts now of
course that is lot of the subtitle of
one of James's books in the case of
sikkim this has really made it possible
this kind of literature has made it
possible to rewrite the history of the
country I say country in a very loose
sense perhaps I'll come back to that in
a while anyway I will come back to
hidden transcripts in a short while and
take a look at is what is in these
documents and what we can learn from
them but before doing so I'd like to
address another area that is quite often
misrepresented by generalization based
on over selectiveness know this is that
Dutch map by the way that you turn
around one of the first maps of Tibet I
was going to make it relevant but I'll
just pass over it this is what they call
the vendor put the map the 17th century
and as you see you have to turn it
around to to read it okay so this is
roller well-known statement the idea of
a demarcated frontier is in itself an
essentially modern conception and finds
little or no place in the ancient world
quite well known and we can find a great
number of other citations to a similar
effect of course curtain was right to a
certain degree
the lack of clarity about the sikkim
ease to that border was the proximate
cause for the young husband mission and
as Richard Burkhardt has very clearly
revealed about the development of the
nation-state of Nepal the the concept of
a border in the South was also extremely
vague but again we cannot think of this
as being representative of the whole
situation now take a look at this okay
so this is a facsimile of a document
from the 17th century from the Annapurna
area and just glance over it don't read
the whole thing the whole thing is about
meticulous boundary creation okay so
there are boundary markers there are
stones there are rivers there are there
are rocks in certain cases you will find
trees and of course every single toponym
has a name and these borders are very
clearly delineated in addition to the
definition of boundaries there is also
very important tradition of boundary
maintenance now so once you've
established your boundary between two
states then you have to make sure there
are regulations governing it and this is
one so it's a little bit off the picture
that Tim what happens if slaves or serfs
run away this is a treaty whereby they
should be returned same thing with
livestock if livestock wanders across
the border the terms under which the
livestock has to be returned so this is
clearly a very it's a very important
aspect of relations between small
pre-modern States in fact the whole
business of boundary formation and
boundary maintenance is a rich and
intriguing field of Investigation that
is absolutely trying out for inquiry
after the collapse of the tibetan empire
following the assassination of the last
emperor in the middle of nine
in the country well centralized
Authority disintegrated and the period
that followed it before the
reconstitution of central authority is
referred to in at least one work as
being a state of anarchy in fact nothing
could be further from the truth this is
the period that sometimes referred to as
the period of hegemon so lots of small
principalities living cheek-by-jowl with
one another about which we have very
little documentation other than what is
mentioned in works such as the biography
of Mel arepa famously studies studied
for its political content by terrell
wily there must have been extremely
rigorous maintenance of boundaries in
order for this complex situation to
survive the situation was presumably
faced by the emergence of the sake o
mungol alliance in the 13th century but
it survived in the himalayan hinterland
and this is the complex that shoe quite
appropriately refers to as democratic
city-states when Ladakh was expelled
from western tibet by gunden sawang in
1683 the boundary excuse me the boundary
between western tibet and the adjacent
the adjacent indian states was finally
fixed there is some recent published
literature in Tibetan about this and
it's absolutely fascinating it deserves
more research when the boundary was
fixed the boundary had to be maintained
and it had to be possible for traders
pilgrims other travelers to cross from
one side to another there's a great deal
of information about the kind of
ceremonies that were maintained every in
order to keep the boundary open the
kinds of delegates who went to check on
the populations of their respective
countries from one side to another an
absolutely fascinating field which we
should give some more attention to
also the ceremonies that attended the
creation of boundaries were quite
spectacular this is another one from
Mustang and it relates to an excuse me
the fixing of the pasture boundaries
among five communities very strange
document okay so as you see the gods are
invoked and then an animal is skinned
and the people who are swearing the
earth sit on this fresh hide naked with
a copper vessel on their heads and a
black yak lead rope around their waists
and they take the oath that they will
maintain the boundaries so as you see
even in terms of ritual a very rich rich
field okay with characteristic modesty
the james cole says in one of his books
that the concept of flight from the padi
states into the refuge of the hills may
not be relevant after about 1950 but
david goellner and sarah among others
have protested that this modesty and
said yes it actually does work in the
case of nepal even down to the present
day now this might seem a little
implausible considering that contrary to
the southeast asian highlands which were
not particularly ruled nepal is a state
and has been at least since the 18th
century and before it was a state it was
a collection of about 60 independent
kingdoms so there's always been some
kind of political authority at some
level in this area how then can James's
essential thesis central thesis be
relevant to the case of Nepal in point
of fact people were moving around
between these city states or the city
states these kingdoms abundantly but it
was a tricky business because you were
winding up in a neighbor's territory and
you didn't always know
how cooperative how welcoming the
neighbor was going to be we've already
seen in the case of the boundary
document I surely a short while ago that
if a slave escaped to the neighboring
principalities then he or she was going
to be returned and to brutal punishment
undoubtedly Sarah gives the example from
the 14th century of the king of middlin
who flees with his family he dies on the
way and he flees to his ally in dolica
he dies his family and his well his sons
and others arrive in De Luca and they
are promptly imprisoned by their ally
there's a great deal of evidence from
the very far west of Nepal Astrid haath
then who is working in lemme at the
moment has found out a great deal about
the way in which small print the
communities moved around within the
territory of the Kali of kings according
to who was being most oppressive in the
taxation so that's around the 15th
century and Nancy Levine has shown in
her work in that area that the
populations were changing their identity
from the party to Tibetan depending on
who was the less oppressive of the
overlords at any given time by and large
well as john de Carre says somewhere
people panic upwards but nobody in his
right mind really wants to go to Tibet
the situation was not particularly
propitious over there so if you're being
oppressed within the Himalayas short of
moving around within the country to an
uncertain future you develop the form of
evasion that takes other forms
and now I come back to the hidden
transcripts that I mentioned a short
while ago this is muscling district the
whole thing as I say was a kingdom that
was established in the 14th century it
broke up the old capital is up here it
broke up into two halves northern Muslim
and southern Muslim the southern bit is
a little bit complicated but to simplify
things just look at this territory it's
the territory of 18 communities called
barragan meaning 12 communities don't
ask me why and inside it there's another
enclaves of those 18 villages 18
communities there are five who somehow
made common cause against the others now
there are archives at all levels over
here so this principality here even
while it was a kingdom and subsequently
after Muslim was incorporated into the
Gorkha state in 1789 it remained a
dukedom except that after the
unification these Dukes were ruling on
behalf of the Gorkha kings since Nepal
also had its own version of the tusa
system that is to say let barbarians
rule barbarians and eventually of course
their power was eroded as the as the the
influence of the center the direct
influence of the center that I came to
came to grow this was the story all over
nepal of course
so this dukedom had its own archive
periodically all 18 communities would
meet sometimes huge cleaner e sessions
more usually representatives of each of
the 18 communities and then they would
meet in secret and come to decisions
about how they were going to deal with
the the presence of the state in
whatever form it was interestingly they
would not meet on the territory of any
one of the 18 communities there were
designated areas of no-man's land where
they would meet because the place on
which you make decisions influences the
quality of the decision or the oath
that's going to be sworn on that
territory so it has to be in neutral
territory such as a riverbed these
documents were then stored in the
community archives here is one archive
coming to light but that's not all I
mentioned that the show you over here
sometimes would make common cause
against the the Dukedom and they would
meet in secret to decide what course of
action they would take against the
Dukedom and they had their own neutral
territory also in a riverbed there were
three different locations which they
would choose they will all meet they
would make a vow of secrecy not to
divulge the fact that they had met and
the documents would be kept in an
archive to which the rest of the Dukedom
had no access the members of the five
sure you were their respective worst
enemies you have most of the bloodiest
battles and right down to the present
time were among members of these five
communities usually about boundary
maintenance in fact so each individual
village also had its secret archive in
which is written which I recorded the
decisions that were made about how to
deal with the troublesome neighbors
three levels of hidden transcripts now
this is a very
rich field as James points out in his
book having literature is a two-edged
sword it gives you an awful lot of
possibilities but it also makes you
vulnerable people can find out about you
also scripts can be developed in order
to mission eyes you which is exactly
what happened with the case of the
lectures and the case of the song
respectively for conversion to Buddhism
and conversion to Christianity so
sometimes it's just as well not to have
a script and this is a well-known tapas
which actually constitutes chapter six
and a half of the art of not being
governed in James's book and it's
something that's quite abundantly
written about particularly by Michael
opitz Markov it's in the case of Lerna
Paul he has an article called they meet
us there fairlawn and shift the myth of
the lost script in which he compares
chang versions nochi versions GU room
versions of this myth it's not just a
matter of a non literate population
excusing themselves so the fact that
they haven't got a script and
subscribing in a rather drown sheehan
sense to the oppressive standards of
their their masters their political
masters it may well be the case that
they did have a script and that they
lost it not necessarily that they were
cheated out of it but once they leave
the clutches of the state and they leave
the literati behind than they are in a
very real sense of population who once
had a script and no longer have one in
the case of Mustang this is an extremely
literate community that is say most
people are not or at least traditionally
were not literate but it has a huge
production of literature though which is
generated by a small group of literate
clerics
in this case how does one avoid the
prying eyes of the state organs I was
once looking at an irrigation document
and irrigation water interestingly is
measured in volume over here now it's
not volumes of water volumetric measures
of water is volumetric measures of seed
which gives you the seed capacity of an
area of land and from there you can tell
the area of land that's involved so I
was in a village which had a very
substantial area of agricultural land
but the irrigation documents were
telling me that the area of land was
vastly smaller than it was and I
couldn't understand this until I asked
one of the ridges I said well you know
how on earth does this work this it
simply doesn't add up me said oh you
have to multiply it by 4 there was a
convention in this community always had
been that everything was divided by 4
just in case somebody from the
government came along and checked the
irrigation records and tax them on the
basis of irrigable loud so even if you
have a script there are ways of hiding
the fact I just invoked the the matter
of comparative mythology the story of
the lost myth in this case comparative
mythology is actually one of the fields
that seems to have disappeared from
Himalayan studies it was very much the
thing when anthropologist first started
working in this part of the world but
over the course of years it's dwindled
and I'm very happy to say that it seems
to be coming to life again there's quite
a lot of work in this direction being
done in the Eastern Himalayas and my own
ex supervisor Nick Allen's the doctoral
dissertation has now been published
miyamme
eret of mythology of the Tula Mariah
there are other topics that have drifted
out of vogue which were very popular in
the early stages of anthropologic
anthropological research in this part of
the world and one of those is kinship
kinship also interestingly seems to be
making a bit of a comeback thanks to the
work of Nancy Levine and also i heard
yesterday thanks to Jeff and Andy who
are finding all sorts of extraordinary
things from southern tibet but i'm not
going to steal their thunder we will
wait until it's published the debate
about identity Tibetan identity focused
to a considerable extent on the
dialectic between kinship and residence
is Tibetan identity based on kinship or
is it based on residence this is
something that came up today and I'm
going to take it I was going to talk
about it in greater detail but since
Jeff did such a wonderful job of talking
about the latest stage in this in this
show we see the non developed the non
development of a boat a ethnic identity
in the Himalayas I think since most
people in the room were present at that
I'll pass over that okay
I was going to go on to talk about
ethnogenesis in Nepal but i'm going to
avoid all that because i can see we're
running out of time I don't want to take
up too much time so I'm going to fast
forward very fast forward to okay to the
Himalayas a scene from Tibet
Tibet has a curious representation of
centers and borders it can't really seem
to make up its mind whether it's the
center or a border yeah this is a very
famous excerpt from one of the done one
text and it tells us about the descent
of the first King from heaven so naughty
tempo comes down from heaven and this is
an expression of sensuality this is an
expression of imperial power Lord of all
under heaven this this heart of this
core of the earth the center of heaven
the heart of the world fenced around by
snow so it's a wonderful place that he
is coming too because it's the best
place on the planet and at the same time
in the Imperial period as Matthew caps
time has shown there was the rise of the
culture of mahavira China that is to say
the king or the Emperor being
represented being represented as the God
at the center of the mandala with the
Empire expanding all around him like a
mandala so Tibet extremely central at
this time compare that with what happens
in the period of the second diffusion
that is to say after about the 10th 11th
century a completely new type of
discourse in the way the Tibetans are
representing themselves ever so slightly
off the picture but you get the gist of
it Tibet is no longer this pure center
of the world it is a bob with a
barbarous board around three times in
the space of about ten lines and the
reason of a look at this fella decides
to manifest in this country is not
because it's the best place in the world
it's because it's the worst place in the
world and he has to convert it so but we
should be okay well this is clearly to
do with a shift in the basis of Tibet's
identity from being founded on
nationalism to being founded on Buddhism
and according to this latter view India
is the center because it's the land of
blood
and Tibet suddenly becomes the barbarous
borderland which needs to be converted
so this is obviously in the interest of
the clarity of this time we're trying to
develop the sense of the importance of
Buddhism but this Auto representation as
a barbarous borderland with respect to
super civilized India isn't entirely
self-deprecating I think we have to read
the narrative extremely carefully you
get a sense of this by examining Tibet's
attitude towards its own borderlands and
this is an extremely ambiguous but
ultimately reverential attitude so after
the collapse of the Empire in the ninth
century the official version is that
Buddhism or at least centralized
Buddhist institutions disappeared from
central Tibet but they were preserved in
under there is this tapas that you find
throughout to bet that the essence of
something can be captured taken away
stored somewhere and then brought back
when the time is propitious you find
this in the case of the term of the
buried treasures for instance if
somebody wants to restore a monastery
first of all you have to carry out a
ritual whereby all the divinities are
taken out of their representations in a
mural stored in a mirror rap to a pillar
and then once the painting has been
finished they can be released back home
like caged birds same kind of thing so
the essence of the country somehow is
exported to the borderlands preserved
brought back in and we see this excerpt
so and oh yes borderland but the
borderland par excellence of course is
the Himalaya guru Rinpoche one of many
quotations from him talking about the
Himalayas as a place where you hide when
that's being invaded or whatever and of
course it quite literally is a place of
refuge even politically we have to
remember after all that the way in which
sikkim and bhutan those two states came
into being was from people fleeing
the high altitude patty state that was
Tibet and fleeing down into the
mountains in order to take refuge there
whether its high although it doesn't
matter James has made that quite clear
he uses the example not of the Himalayas
but of the Andes same thing so people
fleeing down into the into the mountains
for refuge and there are lots of other
examples of the Tibetans taking refuge
in the middle hills of Nepal OEM OEM per
inch Impala in the 13th century going to
Kathmandu finds the place full of
Tibetans who've escaped there because
there have been two years of famines and
the predatory tax collectors are not
letting them off the hook so the
Tibetans are fleeing south into the
Himalayas the borders are ambivalent
places southeaster bet combo is the most
sacred place for the bond pose now this
is their heartland this is their most
sacred mountain but it's also the most
dangerous in all the bonpo literature
it's represented as being full of
poisoners cannibals people who practice
sibling incest and so forth and then
it's not only and you find this
representation of the borderlands or
something rich powerful extremely
dangerous in much of the bumper
literature it's not only the Tibetans
the capuchins were present in Tibet and
here we have father Domenico de far no
writing in the early 18th century well
you can read it yourselves so the reason
was that they were trying to find a
shortcut down to Calcutta this would
have made a great deal of sense if they
could have just gone through the South
Eastern Himalayas but they didn't want
to be eaten alive so he was one of them
30 years later you have father
Costantino delaura who says much the
same thing the people of this region
cannot be subdued since they are very
proud and feed on human flesh if the
missionaries could travel through this
province they've greatly reduce the
length of their voyage but they can't do
this without facing the risk of being
roasted or stewed and becoming
tasty dish for these people same
sentiment echoed by epilator this
desideri later on again talking about
the south eastern himalayas the people
occasionally devour human flesh and do
not hesitate to kill a man when they say
he's young fast and a good complexion
that mother for three minutes okay and I
was absolutely delighted today that Jeff
brought up the topic of some and newbury
happy valley here is a quotation from a
bumper pilgrim who visited the area
circa 1840 to corridor on Tenzin rinchen
and it's clear that shangri-la was not
invented by james hylton first of all
it's really there and this is where Jeff
used to live so the people of that land
were a hundred years old look as if
they're the same age as Tibetans were 30
with the exception of true siblings they
behave quite unashamedly with one
another and speak without reserve so
there is this whole thing of the
lasciviousness of these people as well
they live forever but they're barely
human since monks have to maintain their
patra lineages anyone who says he
doesn't sleep with women is regarded as
a liar to say that you don't need a
woman is very badly considered or else
an indication that you're sterile or
homosexual it causes utter revulsion or
else if you say that you've given up
women he was a monk by the way the
chapel ruthless they think you're making
it up and go for loudly everyone just
laughs in amazement our country is a
hidden land the men are heroes and the
women heroines and everyone who lives
here is really happy now the the demonic
presence in Tibet Tibet as the
personified borderland is of course the
demoness
the prostrate d- this is a 19th century
painting of her the story for those who
don't know it is that when saanson gumbo
is trying to establish buddhism in the
country he marries chinese princess who
wants to enshrine an image of the buddha
a temple has to be built but while we're
trying to build a temple its falls down
at night because the demoness who is
Tibet is flailing her arms and legs and
therefore she has to be pinned down and
temples are built on this is a nice
drawing by mark do Java an architect he
got his wife to lie under a glass coffee
table and drew this so the points
represent the different temples so there
are temples on the hips and shoulders on
the elbows and knees and all the wrists
and ankles so the demon should not be
killed the energy is there it has to be
harnessed it's very creative powerful
energy it just has to be kept under
control a lot of very good feminist
literature on the subject primarily by
janet ghat so among others and it's a
recurring theme so we have this 19th
century version of it there is another
d- is sometimes conflated with this one
and this is the demon as who was the
progenitor of the the human race a
lustful rock demoness who tempted a
meditating monkey who is the
manifestation of Avalokitesvara and
between them they spawned the human race
so this is a later image this is by
gaudy painted some time in the 1990s I
want to come back to that shortly let's
just see how this demoness is
represented in the literature so here we
have a 14th century work which talks
about the farther side the monkey side
and the mother's side which is the
indigenous Tibetan side so the
bodhisattva monkey those who take off
the father a patient trustful
compassionate diligent keen on virtuous
behavior soft-spoken and articulate on
the mother's side their lustful wrathful
mindful of merchandising and profit
covetous and with a highly competitive
spirit laughing
physically strong and courageous and so
on and so on okay so that's the mother's
side one of the first accounts of Tibet
was at annossy Ischia China illustrator
easy talking about he's essentially
reciting the travels of Johann Gruber
another Jesuit so these are some
illustrations from China illustrator and
his reflections on the demonic nature of
the women here in Tibet the women are so
ugly that they see more like Devils than
humans the answer recurring trope for
religious reasons they never wash
themselves with water but only with
totally rancid butter moreover besides
ex alien a tolerable stench they're so
stained by the set butter that you would
call them ghouls and not humans now in
the 1975 ascent of mount everest there
is a story by well it's recorded in a
book or footprints on the peak
mountaineering in China its history of
mountain by Joe Cheng and probably
pronouncing it wrong and there's a love
story in there it's a love story between
the Han Chinese climb a danger Xiang and
the Tibetan woman climber been pok they
fall in love and she as it says in the
book bursts into his life now his
parents have already found him a nice
fiancee back home in China but now
Tibetan girl had burst into his life i
quote wouldn't his parents be displeased
but his parents very understanding and
then jochen goes on to talk about this
marriage between the civilized the
civilizing chinese climber and the
native Tibetan climber okay now I'm
going to finish in a couple of images so
we have this tapas that keeps coming up
about the
savage dangerousness of these this
femininity which is Tibet forms of
resistance I mean they're just the last
couple of images here as I said can be
very subtle and the more repressive the
state is the sutler the forms of
resistance have to be sometimes I'm
going to finish with a couple of
paintings so this is not a subtle
painting this the painter might get into
serious trouble if this painting
painting were ever publicly seen so on
the left you have a representation of
Tibetan nature and on the right you have
a representation of Tibetan culture
which is inscribed on rock money stones
and so forth so here you can see this
white dove which is having the life
crushed out of it by a red cord and here
you can see a rock with images engraved
on it surrounded so tightly by a chains
that blood is coming out of it because
there's not a particularly subtle form
of form of expression but remember this
demon asst remember that she has chained
down but that this is where the savage
power of Tibetan creativity lives look
carefully at these paintings again now
we've seen this one with the temples
pinning her down we've seen this one
from the 19th century and you can see
that there are temples they're all in
place in this one this modern 1990s
there is nothing pinning her down so one
wonders what was in the painters mind
when he created this thang
but but first I wanted to start with a
small anecdote since Charles began with
mountaineering I had a brother-in-law
who was a relatively modest mean so
unlike the millionaires in America who
hire guides to drag them up every summit
in the world he decided he would have a
more modest goal of climbing the highest
peaks in every state in the United
States and I got to know of this plan
when he came to Connecticut and I mean
he had just conquered I think the
highest point in Delaware which was a a
you know toxic waste site behind some
trailers the it turns out that the
highest peak in Connecticut is halfway
up a mountain the peak of which is in
Massachusetts so I I thought this is one
of the few reasons I can find for loving
my states that it doesn't even have a
mountain its highest point belongs
actually to a section of a mountain that
the peak is elsewhere the I want to
begin actually by invoking Clint
Eastwood who wants shortly before he
shot someone said a man has to know his
limitations and I think this is actually
a case of me not knowing my limitations
and being persuaded by the charisma of
the conference and Sarah's invitation to
devise something to say in any case the
the term zonia as you some of you may
know is not my term but was invented by
villain bunch Kendall
and I was persuaded that it would be a
useful way to describe what I understood
to be so Mia vilem of course believes
that so Mia extends eastward through the
Himalayas all the way to Afghanistan I
thought I had bit off more than I could
chew just dealing with upland Southeast
Asia so I told the villain that this was
up to him that he was in charge of
everything west of Assam and Manipur and
so on and that was if you like his
responsibility the I also and for good
reasons I thought because Tibet was an
empire a contending state that reached
as far as Burma it was like the kingdoms
of the Andes because it's arable was at
a high altitude it became in a sense of
a expansionary state which the hills of
mainland Southeast Asia did not have for
all practical purposes so it's and since
Nepal also had a rather venerable state
as well it seemed to me that at least my
analysis didn't didn't work I also felt
as I tried to make clear that the
conditions of state control and what I
call distance demolishing technologies
that were available after the end of the
Second World War and the idea of
expanding state sovereignty to the
physical borders of a state changed in a
sense the increase the vulnerability if
you like to control and sovereignty
being extended into the Highlands and so
if if despite these warnings brave
people like Sarah and I
think that this analysis can be extended
to for some purposes in any case into
the Himalayan area then it's fine with
me but you're on your own the so I think
one possible contribution that the idea
behind zonia might make is the following
and that is one should never thought
lessly take on the territorial divisions
authorized by the nation-state as units
of analysis that is if you want to study
a state territoriality then perhaps you
want to take those units seriously but
otherwise it seems to me that it is for
most purposes and for most questions and
foremost analytical objectives to take
the borders of the nation-state a
comparatively new invention not even
hegemonic in Europe in terms of its
boundaries before 1500 makes probably no
sense at all so and the question of what
the unit of analysis should be instead
of reifying the nation-state might be a
cultural zone might be uh excuse me it
might be a linguistic zone it might be
circuits of exchange and as discussed
this afternoon it might be the
radiations of emigrant emigration and
backward migration that knits places
together it might be particularly
relevant in this area a watershed a
river valley it could be a ecological
zone of certain flora and fauna that is
to say
the unit of analysis and its kind of
geographical definition ought to depend
on the kind of problem that you pose for
yourself and not on the territorial
divisions authorized by the nation-state
unless it's those divisions in
themselves that you are interested in
understanding and pursuing as I said I
in an effort to prepare for this
conference I am reading Sandman shakes
psych book on the history of Tibet and I
confess to you that I've only up to
about a hundred page 125 and I wish to
God that he had put in the kinds of
things that you sometimes find in
Tolstoy novels of family relationships
names of sages names of famous monks and
the schools with which they are
associated because to me it's an almost
impossible history to follow that he
takes me directly to the weeds and I
have not yet gotten out of the of the
weeds and it seems to me so far I may it
may it may change but so far people
stumble back from northern India with a
new Sutra found a new order or new
monastery understand that monasteries or
units of power in themselves and then
our political units that are serious
units themselves but it it seems as if
reading this much of san van schaick
that the enterprise of Tibetan history
and politics is driven by sacred texts
and their charismatic proponents and the
the little unruh pressed Marxist and
materialist in me wants to ask well
isn't there something else behind this
is this set of regional interest so in
for example in Southeast in Burma
there's a long dispute between Buddhist
sects that in which the point of
contention appears to be whether you
should wear the robe over one shoulder
or both shoulders and this goes on for
several generations but it has to do
fairly fairly clearly with the struggle
between differently situated
geographical monasteries and the princes
who are associated with those particular
monasteries and who are the patrons of
those monasteries it's not that people
aren't willing to die over whether the
road should be worn on one on one
shoulder or another but it's not the end
it's not the only stake that is involved
in this seemingly theological dispute so
I find myself asking in the context of
this theological textually based Tibetan
history I want the social history for
which the documents don't exist I want
the material basis the way I confess the
way in which the kind of instinctive
Marxist desire for a material under
footing or material foundation for some
of these for some of these struggles
might be elaborated the so at what in
one of the papers today was invoked the
idea of everyday religion and I would
have welcomed a detailed analysis of the
relationship between local religious
practice and the larger theological
texts
it's it seems to me that the religion of
popes and Archbishop's and doctrinal
leaders is almost never the religious
understanding and practice of their
ordinary folk adherents and the question
and there's a process it seems to me of
localization a process of syncretism and
I believe sometimes a process of
profanation as well that takes that
takes place in this context and that the
translation of textual great tradition
religion and its local understanding
sendings and practice is an important a
sociological and cultural task for
anthropologists and for historians I
remember a long time ago magnificent
little article by McKim Mariette who did
a census of the gods in a Indian village
and and which casts worshipped which
gods and it turned out that the lower
castes worship predominantly local gods
whereas the higher caste worship gods
that were either provincial or national
and so it was a an effort to sort of
understand that was truly a census of
spirits and gods and it was able to he
was able to relate that to the religious
practices of different social castes
within within the village in that
respect it seems to me that this kind of
analysis has to be done not just with
religious texts but it has to do with
social and political text as well that
is to say whether we're talking about
nationalism or socialism or communism or
revolutions there is a full
understanding of what's going on and
there is and the folk understanding may
differ from village to village and
problems the province as someone pointed
out there as
many revolutions of 1848 in France as
there are villages in France and if you
ask in a in a oral history one of the
first oral histories collected from a
French tenant farmer who would live
through the Revolution of 1848 this is a
an oral history taken maybe 30 years
later he was asked what the Revolution
of 1848 was about he was illiterate man
and he knew about universal suffrage he
knew what happened in Paris he said it
was the danger of conscription and the
end of the salt tax so for him the
Revolution of 1848 was the salt tax and
the danger of being conscripted into the
into the army that was his Revolution of
1848 if you want to understand so my
argument is that the that let's say in
Vietnam during the revolution if you
want to understand communism the last
place you want to go is to the texts of
Ho Chi Minh and to the elites you there
is a folk communism right in which the
understanding of what the revolution
means are quite different the same is
true for folk nationalism as well and
one of the most beautiful expressions of
this difference is i think it's the road
to wigan pier by orwell where he
contrasts the socialism of the pipe
smoking sandal wearing a tweed jacket
'add university socialist with socialist
that you'd meet on any saturday night in
a pub and tries to describe exactly what
their different understandings of
socialism are and it seems to me that
that the our ability to kind of move and
track it's not that these things are not
in dialogue constantly and don't
influence one another but it seems to me
they can only be seen as a kind of
moving system of varying influence and
change over time that is that is
evolving I wanted to say something about
borders and I take Charles this point
that borders were a lot more important
than
kurzin thought they were but I'm
wondering if we might read some of his
texts against the grain as well that
this was an effort to claim and
establish and essentially tenuous and
difficult border and the emphasis on the
border and its maintenance and the fines
and so on when you say slaves have to be
returned and their punishment is going
to be terrible it tells you that a lot
of people are moving slaves across the
border the reason that that Puritan
Divine's denounced fornication is
because it was common so it seems to me
that one can read a set of documents I'm
not sure I don't know enough to know how
these documents might be read against
the grain so I leave that to other wiser
heads but it seems to me that the effort
to establish borders and the amount of
if you like textual space devoted to
them may tell us about the tenuous pneus
and difficulty of borders the I think
that borders are often seen as obstacles
to movement Commerce and so on and yet
it seems to me that every border is also
an opportunity the Roma and Sinti the
gypsies are what I think of as order
specialists that is to say wherever
there are two different jurisdictions
with different legal regimes different
customs and so on there is something
that can be moved profitably in each
direction across that that border and
one finds Roma and Sinti clustered at
the border because that in a sense is
their advantage that is there
nice to take advantage of these
different jurisdictions and different
legal orders and in that sense a border
is an extraordinary opportunity to move
people to move drugs to move tobacco and
so on I wanted I wanted by way of a
Southeast Asian anecdote to at least
raise the question of what I might call
provocatively the scramble for the
Himalayas that is a friend of mine got
permission from the World Bank to spend
a year in Laos as an authorized
ethnographer of the World Bank not
authorized it wasn't an official history
of the world bank but they just let him
tag along and he described to me his his
first meeting with the head of the World
Bank in vientiane and as he was having a
chat with the director of the world
banking noticed on the wall behind him a
map not quite like that but you have to
imagine a map of the international
borders of Laos just the tracing of the
outline of the entire country of laos
and the only town indicated it all by a
little star was venti on but in this
huge outline map of laos were all kinds
of little kidney-shaped trapezoid
parallelogram blotches it looked as if
it had kind of broken out in a great
rash all over Laos there were these
little shapes each of them different
from any other and they all had writing
in them at the end of the interview he
asked ahead of the World Bank of what
the what were all those things in the in
the map and the director of the world
bank took him to the map and showed him
that
all of these little shapes were a
territorial ization of bio reserves
endangered species reserves flora and
fauna international hundreds of NGOs had
been given limited sovereignty over all
of these areas that then belonged to
them for certain purposes of control of
egress and and the taking of animals in
the taking of wood and so on may be
worthy purposes but to look at when I
heard this story it struck me that there
is a kind of NGO scramble for
territoriality and certain aspects of
sovereignty and not just over over
nature that it works out very nicely for
laos because local officials are paid
virtually nothing and when they do this
they get salaries they get perks it
allows the provincial government to
actually operate in more expansive way
than they would otherwise be able to the
same takes place in Vietnam and it seems
to me without knowing much about what's
happening in in the Himalayas is that
the extraordinary thing about the
Himalayas is that they are the
headwaters for all the great rivers of
Asia and if the scramble for resources
is a scramble for water then Tibet in a
sense is is the key prize and if they're
already 300 400 and the number of dams
on the Chinese side an indian indian
side is quite extraordinary but in a
sense the hydrological future of every
state in asia depends on what happens in
the headlands of all these great rivers
and the idea that India and China should
look a not to mention Thailand and so on
all them should look covetously on the
opportunities presented by the control
of these waters and the electorate
hydroelectric power that can be
generated plus as i understand it a
tremendous amount of mineral resources
and they a point that i made in the
bookends Omiya was that before the mid
20th century these peripheral areas of
nomadic peoples of hunters and gatherers
of sweden cultivators of thinly
populated areas people were so dispersed
their products could not be effectively
taxed or gathered the people themselves
couldn't be controlled these were
considered to be fiscally sterile zones
of the globe and that was most of the
globe in fact historically but however
in late industrial capitalism the need
for the minerals of the aerospace
industry for the electronics industry
hydroelectric sites rare kind of
minerals of one kind or another oh and
not to mention timber all of these areas
are in a sense resource frontiers that
turn out to be absolutely vital to
States in terms of their their finances
their control and so there's these areas
that were essentially no man's lands a
lot of interest are now finally
desperately of interest at two minutes
or not the I wanted to say something
about the way in which we study faraway
places I've been always working on
Southeast Asia I've never been
comfortable with the idea that at least
in the American Academy every three or
four years if you're lucky you get a
year
off and you go and do some research or
maybe a summer and I've always been
secretly envious of the the colonial
officials who in a sense burned their
bridges and went native and spent a
whole lifetime doing scholarship in the
country in which they lived and it seems
to me that that we the world we would
like to create which happens in some
places in Southeast Asia it's true for
Indonesia it's true for thailand now
it's certainly true for Malaysia that
there is a really substantial
intellectual world of the universities
in these countries in which if you want
to be a student of Indonesia or Malaysia
or Thailand you had better do work that
is recognized for its excellent
excellence and is respected in those
countries you cannot just be a North
American expert on tile and if they
don't know you in Thailand if they don't
want to listen to what you have to say
if they don't read what you write then
you're likely to not be writing anything
of great interest and it seems to me we
want to kind of create a world that's
equal in that respect and to have a
world in which it is possible for people
to have by national research careers to
live let's say every other year in Nepal
every other year in the US both for
Himalayan scholars themselves and for
American and Western European scholars
it seems to me that the creation of this
genuine cosmopolitan moving back and
forth that also helps create an
intellectual community of kind of
conceptual sharing as well and
collaboration would be a far healthier
situation in the situation we have now
in which most universities value us for
being exotic specialists in area
that nobody knows anything about thank
you so much in Charles could you please
join in the interest of all of our time
Charles perhaps would you just take a
couple of minutes to respond to these
thoughts yes visibly respond because all
I can see is that I agree heartily with
everything it's but a pull up on one of
two things yes the idea that we should
treat the text with some suspicion I
absolutely agreed if people are
generating an awful lot of literature
about a particular subject is because
they're not working something is not
working and so they need to keep
repeating the exercise and the greater
the density of this volume of material
the bigger the issue most here is the
issue I was just trying to think about
border documents of this sort and the
most elaborate ones I've seen are
actually from north eastern tibet from
under i have a collection on the
computer which are drawn maps painted
maps in fact which actually showed
linear demarcations of grazing rights
and of course it's axiomatic that in
that part of the world this is where
pasture boundaries are a very deadly
business there is a rather Sicilian
style of settling disputes over
boundaries and tragically it's all goes
on so there is an enormous loss of life
in this area and this seems to be
commensurate with the the production of
maps which are completely useless for
this purpose here and the other thing I
think that that's worth mentioning is
that borders are not just then all those
lines on the ground or a number of
landmarks they are actually terribly
complicated things and this is also
similar Jim just alluded to and I'm
thinking of a particular part of Nepal
whether it to borders there was one
international border between Tibet and
Nepal and then there was the fiscal
border which was a couple of days south
and this was a very interesting no man's
land which made it well it wasn't no
mountain I was it was rich it was deeply
textured territory which made it
possible for certainty people to become
extremely wealthy since effects
effectively everybody who was north of
the fiscal border was being treated like
a non-native non-national so the and the
border kept moving up and down over the
course of about a hundred years so it's
not just a simple line on the ground
it's a very English we say it's a it's a
very rich textured nuanced environment
and what Casillas deserves a lot more
research in example of why it's so
important to be stimulated and provoked
by people who are not so closely
associated with the region you've
refresh ups with your ideas and Charles
thank you for a wonderful presentation
but ends with this very suggestive
metaphor the art of not being pinned
down so let's all go and have a drink
and thank you charles and Jim